So who is the woman you like now
?My name is Ai, or my lover in a distant world.It's far away.There's no such
thing as a
long-distance relationship.
It's fun just being there and I can only feel my heartbeat Is that the beginning of
the day when I'm happy?
I wonder if it's more likely that it's a general condition
[Music
] If possible, it's preferable to include numerical values
.
But, Yukimura, the money spent on building a team is a lot of people who give presents on the saddle.
You say that Suke-kun's feelings are strong -- this is of course true, but it's probably been more than two years
since I've been hugging you every night
when I go to bed
.  Music]
Once,
4 minutes to the assembly hall h That means 365 multiplied by
730 Kanssan His waterfall tuna index is 130 times my flower
If you look at it objectively, I hope you're mistaken
The true form of a person in love
If you don't have this kind of feeling, you say you don't like it
Aika-chan is this girl 4 a